hi rich and adam um
this is madeline i live in redondo beach
i just have a question about
romance um i recently went through a big
breakup i was living with my boyfriend
and i had to make kind of a life shift
and so
now i'm dating again i've been going on
the apps
and it's kind of hard to find someone
with a similar mindset
i've been a vegan for 11 years i'm a
long time listener of rich's podcast and
my ex was an ironman athlete and so
because of that relationship i got
really into endurance
running and i ran my first marathon last
year
anyway going through the app swiping
through
i try to look for pictures of runners
but they're just not coming up i don't
know if it's because
it's la and i'm getting a lot of actors
or so on
and i was just wondering if you guys had
some advice of where to find these guys
it's also kind of hard with
covid um because i can't really like
join a running club right now so anyways
thought this could be a fun
question to answer in your podcast love
the show
um thanks so much bye wow well thanks
madeline
it is a fun question it is a very fun
question and it
it it brings up all kinds of emotions in
me because on the one hand
let's face it i am a de facto
relationship expert
adam by pure dent of being in a
relationship for 22 years all i had to
do was be in a relationship for a long
time yeah and now i'm a
a relationship expert you're an expert
but the thing is
you're an expert of your relationship
yes this is true
on the other hand i have no idea
how to give advice on dating i haven't
dated in
decades particularly dating advice in a
pandemic
or anything having to do with dating
apps because i've never been on a dating
app and were you entirely were you a
serial dater
no i i'm the guy who goes from
relationship to relationship
i've never been able to date like
multiple people at the same time i don't
know how people do that
so essentially i'm i'm very ill-equipped
uh
to help you out here uh
and and one of my kind of core things is
that i always root any advice that i
give
on based basis you know i base it on my
personal experience right i have no
personal experience with dating apps
trying to date in a pandemic no
or having to date you know in any recent
decade
so no seven days with that you know i
feel like
like dk or davey should sit here because
they know well
much more about this than i do um but i
will say this
um you know obviously the instinct to
connect with like-minded people is a
good instinct
and that's certainly compromised in a
situation in which personal
personal interaction is so compromised
um and and and i can say generally that
that i think there's a lot of good in
dating apps and helping people figure
out how to connect with
people that are like-minded to them but
they're not
an effective stand-in for what is or or
or is not
real like i don't know i have friends
that are on raya have you ever seen raya
no and and people they spend like tens
of thousands of dollars on like
like like basically these show reels to
basically
you know like it's it's crazy what goes
into like creating profiles on this on
this app
so that people can look is raya like the
high-end one
yeah it's like a crazy yeah yeah you
have to get invited on and all that kind
of stuff
um i have a friend who's been um
digitally
dating somebody for weeks um that he
just had never met
they spent like countless hours on
facetime and texting and stuff like that
and then they finally met in person the
other
the other day and uh he was like he knew
immediately that he didn't want to date
her
even though he was like enamored with
this person on facetime for
umpteen hours the minute that he met her
he was like this is not gonna work
wow which i thought was a really
interesting
um testament to the
you know the um fallibility of
visual of of trying to interact with
somebody digitally that or he needs to
run the 4x48
maybe he does yeah i don't know i don't
i don't know i mean
you know i think there are no running
clubs right now
because of the pandemic but what you can
do is you can still go running and you
can go running where people go running
even though the clubs have canceled
their their get-togethers and you can do
like digital networking in those clubs
like facebook groups yeah you can do all
of that
and you can trust and chance encounters
and
double down on your you know analog
experiences
but i also think because
we're being restricted from interacting
with people
in this moment that it's a unique
opportunity
to do the work on yourself that maybe
you have been reluctant to to date
in the sense that you reconfigure your
focus
rather than chasing a mate or trying to
find that person
that you think is going to make your
life better that'll make you feel better
or fill some
whole instead try to work on becoming
the person that your
ideal mate would want to be with and i
think when you
shift that focus in that manner you in
turn
over time become like this magnet
who then attracts the right person to
you as opposed to being the person
who's out there fishing or chasing all
of the time
so it's like a power differential and
it's kind of a spiritual equation
but i think it's i think it it's it
works and it's effective like
i just know so many people are it's like
they're unhappy in their lives they're
like if i just could date this person if
i could just find this person like my
life would be better
but they don't have what that person
they aspire to be with
they don't have the qualities that that
person would find attractive
right and they think that that person is
going to complete them
when in truth you have to become
complete yourself
right right and when you can focus on
that on that personal growth
trajectory that you're on you become
this more attractive person to
the mate that you seek or the world more
broadly yeah
that's great advice um
you know going on the apps is
overfishing
and tuning into yourself is sustainable
fishing
is that let me think about that that's
my that's my
that's my tuning in yourself is
sustainable fishing
yes you did
tune into yourself you become the
sustainably fish your soul
you become the fish they all chase all
right
i can live with that yeah i got it i
like that one i don't know if that was
very helpful to madeline but
well it's disappointing because no one
wants to be told just tune into yourself
and forget about dating because
when you you're out of a room but i
don't have the answer like oh you should
call this number
or go to this website and here's where
all the people are hanging out secretly
no well there are those secret parties i
know there are there was an article in
the la times about the secret gyms
yeah did you see that no i i saw the
secret parties one um
yeah i saw that too but there was one
about like people who've set up gyms in
their garages and there's like a whole
underground network
of where because all the hardcore
fanatic gym rats needed a place to go
and all the gyms closed and so
they're like speakeasies right right
like you got to know somebody in a
password and
you can get it that's what these parties
are right and like and
like the parties are getting shut then
garcetti shut down like the power to
some of these houses
oh he did yeah yeah yeah they had it all
done yeah but so maybe
i don't know madeline i don't have the i
don't have the past password for any of
these eyes wide shut
you know running speakeasy situations
they probably exist somewhere they
probably do you don't want to go
right um but you know you're going to be
all right that's a fun question
you're obviously a fun person that's
going to be and you live in redondo
beach
go run on the strand go run up to
manhattan beach and back there's so many
people out there
exactly i'm sure that you can find
somebody and i'm not saying avoid actors
but avoid actors yeah that
that's definitely i love that
[Music]
you